ich habe mal eine kamera und jetzt
kommen wir anrufe ein fuchs da muss mal
kurz zu sagen kurzen moment was genau
und herzlich willkommen damit zu hörende
video ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
außer dass ich jetzt eine neue kamera
hab ich hoffe das sieht man habe ich die
letzte woche auch damit verbracht
also es ist wirklich extrem viel zeit
dafür drauf gegangen ich habe 45 stunden
ganze instagram durchs kreuz tage durch
bamba diese stories 12 rein und ich
wollte halt alle geilen werbungen die
ich dort angezeigt bekommen wir
bestellen das habe ich auch gemacht zum
größten teil es war nur sehr schwer weil
man muss sagen ich habe glaube ich also
so ein öffentliches profil ich habe ja
auch in blau und karten bei instagram
oder das jetzt irgendwie hier besonders
im vordergrund zu stellen aber ich hab
halt ein blauer golf instagram worauf
ich auch sehr stolz und blind hat auf
einfach nicht jeder hat doch viel spaß
auf jeden fall habe ich das gefühl wir
werten fast keine werbung und angezeigt
weswegen ich mir extra nen neuen akku
hersteller und da kam so viele werbung
ich war wenig erschrocken mit wie viel
werbung ihr auch alle wahrscheinlich bei
uns zugewandert werden aber ich muss
sagen das waren extreme sachen dabei wir
haben fünf sechs sachen bestellt ich
habe mich bei sachen angemeldet und das
zeigt euch alles jetzt wir packen das
aus es sind einige pakete eingegangen
und ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß bei
dem video lässt glauben nicht bevor wir
allerdings staaten gibt es noch einen
sponsor des heutigen videos und das ist
dream i genauer gesagt der neue dream ii
heute das ist der trinität 30 zeigt euch
jetzt mal was ja so kann und vor allem
was die vorteile vor dem dänen sind
ach so und hier vielleicht direkt macht
ihr seht dass hier sammelt sich der
ganze dreck das wird hier so schön rein
geschleudert jetzt kann man ganz einfach
die aufklappen und dann halt ganz
entspannt sorgen der trinität 30 ist
brandneu öffnen markt kommen und aktuell
im early bird preis erhält legen also
könnt bis zum 26 juni ordentlich geld
sparen
der c30 hat 150.000 rpm starke saugkraft
und eine laufzeit von 90 minuten damit
ist er also leistungsstärker als
beispielsweise der dyson 15 der
kohlefaser körper macht das gerät
besonders leicht und einfach zu halten
außerdem passt der sauger seine
saugleistung automatisch auf teppich
oder harte oberflächen an ihr habt aber
auch vier stufen auto medium und turbo
und super eindruck ist ihr könnt euch
die aufsätze zusammenhang wie ihr wollt
also auch ganz einfach so dass
staubsauger benutzen
und man hat wirklich einen aufsatz für
jede gegebenheit wir kommen in den
kleinsten ecken ihr kommt in die größten
ecken hier kommt auch die größten
flächen alles kein problem also mit dem
ausland habe ich die küche so schön
sagen wir so schnell können sie gar
nicht gucken
[Musik]
also leute die gern die beschreibung ab
dort ist der w30 ganz oben verlängert
danke fürs sponsor dieses videos und wir
machen jetzt weiter jetzt muss ich sagen
habe ich euch auf jeden fall auch lange
genug warten lassen
wir starten mit der ersten werbung die
blende ich euch hier mal ein und zwar
nennt sich das motors oder modems keine
ahnung wir schauen erst mal die website
an
ich habe dafür knapp 30 euro bestellt
das paket ist auch schon da und dann
packen wir das ganze mal aus ich habe ja
direkt gehört zeit von matthäus mottos
brutalos hatte mal hat das miteinander
zu tun
schöne grüße an dieser stelle wir
befinden uns hier auf jeden fall auf der
website und ihr seht schon hier kann man
einiges kaufen habe ich bereits vor fünf
tagen war gemacht der versand ging
ultraschall ich glaube das paket war in
zwei teilen oder fast direkt am nächsten
tag ihren ihr könnt das ja hier mal
sehen zum beispiel könnte man jetzt wohl
kaufen 14-49 manchmal 21 eur 36 also 60
prozent ist das konzept von tatums ganz
gut zusammengefasst sie kaufen produkte
aus überproduktion fehldrucke saisonale
produkte selbst im jahre produkt selbst
so nahe saison jahre hätten das
ausführung sehr sozial oder saisonale
produkte kurzes oder teils über
schrittes mindesthaltbarkeitsdaten geile
idee es ist günstiger für den kunden und
es ist vor allem nachhaltig ich bin das
auch so traurig wenn immer so viele
sachen weggeschmissen werden ihr seht
ihr screenshot von meiner bestellung ich
habe für ein reich eur 790 bestellt mit
versand haid und ab 20 euro 55 gespart
also das ist nice vertraulich ist
einfach mal drauf diese summe von das
paket packen wir zusammen aus
also hier ist auf jeden fall einiges
drin ich muss sagen ich feiere das echt
und ich muss die nächsten zwei monate
glaube ich auch absolut keine
süßigkeiten mehr bestellen deshalb
sowieso nicht so viel süßigkeiten aber
manchmal hat
und ich hab schon gesagt das konzept von
den ultra ultra ist und michael hat noch
mal freundlich geld sparen
deswegen waren das ausnahmsweise mal
eine gute inseln werbung von all diesen
ganzen in sachen werbung nicht gebannt
schauen wir mal hier haben wir quandt
tipps habe angst
schaden doch mal noch mal okay dann
haben wir hier ruft schon abgeschaltet
und anime auch nicht schlecht ab wie von
mag ich sehr gerne dann mama xxl packung
weiter geht es mit dem modell des quiz
wie ich finde ich ultra lecker
dann haben wir hier absolut geschmolzene
butter trotzdem aber noch haltbar bis
zum 27 06 also da kannst du wirklich
nicht mehr kann oder es war irgendwie so
eine ehrliche das schade die sachen sind
halt ein bisschen an geschmeidig aus dem
ich will ganz meckere ich habe sie auch
einen guten preis bekommt dann haben wir
noch colaflaschen und das war's dann
auch schon
jedes schiff packen ist aufgegangen sich
gerade weil wir sind ein paar chips also
motors kann ich eigentlich nur positives
sagen man spart geld danke instruments
für diese weise werbung wo man werde
jetzt mittlerweile schon zehn nach zwölf
aber ich muss dazu also zu mozart uns
noch mal ganz kurz was sagen und zwar
ist das aufgefallen also gut ich befinde
mich jetzt hier auf der seite trust
pilot und dort ist es eigentlich üblich
dass es bei zu jedem unternehmer so gibt
es immer leute die schlechte sachen
schreiben und da hast du eigentlich auch
nicht 5 und 5 sterne trotzdem schneidet
es hier nicht so gut ab und viele leute
beschweren sich auch hier zum beispiel
abzocke bei allen verglichenen produkten
14 war es gleich teuer oder teurer zum
discounter es ist halt wirklich voll max
ohne weil das geht ja es ist ja no go
und ich habe das bei meinen produkten
zum teil auch gemerkt ich habe einfach
mal alle sachen die ich dort bestellt
habe verglichen mit den preisen wenn man
sie halt neu cortados hat mir 20 euro
angezeigt dass ich als 20 euro gespart
haben es wird nicht 20 euro seien also
ich würde sagen maximal 10 euro aber
halt nicht 20 das war ein bisschen viel
sollte ich einfach noch gesagt haben
also weil ich habe das ein bisschen zu
positiv glaube ich dargestellt
ich weiß gar nicht womit ich
weitermachen soll ich würde sagen zu
fall und ich habe es schon mal alles im
kühlschrank
genau hier aber es sollte alles für ihn
kühlt und warte ich 100 wirtschaft das
da ist auf jeden fall meine nächste
bestellung und zwar habe ich europas
größten setzt dach bestellt auch hier
mal wieder einen blick
und deswegen ist angekommen ist ultra
schwer eigentlich habe ich denn auch für
mein büro bestellt aber ich habe jetzt
erst mal zu meiner wohnung verlassen und
wir packen jetzt mal auf dieser seite
habe ich ihnen übrigens bestellt den
größten sitzsack der ach so der welt
sogar ach so ich dachte europas oder
habe ich mich vertan wir haben hier 1500
liter memory schaumstoff füllung und so
kann das dann aussehen und ich muss
sagen ich zeigen euch morgen nochmal er
ist wirklich riesig also das ding da
kann man nicht meckern für den preis
nicht ich glaube das ist jetzt hier
sozusagen da sitzt und alles was in
diesem gefährt gesamterlebnis 5 über 25
kilo weg muss jetzt hier ein
ach so das habe ich noch gar nicht
gesagt gekostet hat der 160 euro also da
erwarte ich uns auch keine qualität
so dass bläst sich gerade automatisch
auf und deswegen ich stecke das jetzt
einfach mal hier rein und dann wird der
sitzsack wie aus magie zum größten sitz
europas
[Applaus]
vielleicht habe ich auch was falsch
gemacht und ich muss erst noch die folie
abziehen das plastik den genuss solcher
abschluss war irgendwie ein bisschen ja
ist ja auch logisch nicht also für alle
die sich schon immer gefragt habe wie
größe ist er ist der grösste sitz
europas so roos und ich muss sagen er
ist auch wirklich mega betriebe also
dank an dieser stelle an instagram dass
ich jetzt auch den größten sitzer
europas hier liegen haben da kann man
auf jeden fall jetzt so liegen bleiben
müsste manchmal wenden und hier steht
drauf sofort belastbar wächst bis zu
sieben tage also der wird jetzt immer
größer und größer und die haben sogar
noch harry potter zugestimmt mega gau
also da kann man sich wirklich nicht
beschweren
ach so nicht soll jetzt zur kammer
schütteln was geht ab heute und morgen
gab es schon den nächsten tag hier haben
wir den sitzer kriegen ich zeige euch
jetzt einfach mal so auf der kamerablick
das glaube ich gar nicht so großen
moment hat er ist auf jeden fall nicht
klein erhält sich mega riesig aber schon
sehr groß also beweis muss fairerweise
sagen ich kenne jemand der früher noch
größeren sitze aber das gute ist ja er
wird noch sieben tage lang größer leute
das geht ich bin gerade mal in mein büro
gefahren und hatte nämlich eine wohnung
ausziehen bestellt aber dass wir
trotzdem ganz gut gepasst weil ich muss
wohl noch einige samen zeigen die kann
ich euch nur hier zeigen auf jeden fall
haben wir hier eine sendung und ich weiß
glaube ich was es ist ein elektronischer
kokkola also ich wusste nicht dass es so
was gibt aber das hört sich erst mal
mega geil dann weil ich hab zu hause
selber einen kopfhörer und wenn ja auch
noch elektronisches alter wie geil ist
das denn
okay ich bin gespannt machen wir den
elektro in kokkola mal auf also es ist
auf jeden fall etwas aus china ich kann
zumindest nichts verstehen was auf der
verpackung steht ich hoffe dass in
batterien dabei das fach mit
ob irgendwas gestellt ohne batterie okay
das ist ohne batterien
das hier sind dann anscheinend diese
tentakeln sage ich mal
die steckt man dann einfach hier rein
für die es interessiert ich glaube ich
habe 24 euro dafür bezahlt
wahrscheinlich kosten die dinger in
china so ja zwei also dem also die
qualität ist jetzt noch nicht so
überzeugend wir schauen jetzt mal
deswegen ist leider leer kleinen moment
sonne ist ready for charging justiert
hier würde ich es interessiert ich habe
tatsächlich in dieser einen woche über
300 euro ausgegeben für irgendwelche
instagram werden und so rein und sachen
wegen welche t shirts oder spotify oder
irgendwelche business coaching programme
habe ich nicht gekauft werden und das
video war noch viel zu lang werden
also ich hab mir das interessanteste
genommen aber ist er trotzdem mehr geld
wollte ich mal gesagt haben leute live
test für euch wir nehmen das dingen und
stülpen ist über den kopf und machen es
an alle altersklassen films also ich hab
eigentlich erhofft das geht dann auch
automatisch hoch und runter also halt so
der für 24 euro ich kann nicht wirklich
kaum daran erinnern dass ich mal schrott
gekauft hat für 24 euro nehme ich noch
schlechter fand als dieses ding ohne
witz normale kopfhörer die kosten 56
euro die sind wirklich ultras tätig sein
und das macht richtig spaß sich damit
selber den kopf zu grauen aber das ding
hier ist absolut schlecht also es ist
nicht mehr geil das so zu machen es
fühlt sich an als würde irgendwie keine
ahnung
diese zentralen erbringen hat kein gutes
maß haare gefühlen manchmal das so sagen
kann deswegen die nächste instanz werden
die mir angezeigt wurde war folgende von
kernschmelze da kann man seine eigene
schokolade sozusagen gestalten und sich
dann nach hause schicken lassen das war
übrigens auch das erste produkt was ich
überhaupt bestellt habe aus
irgendwelchen instruments ich bin euch
hier mal die bestellung 112 91 bis 94
versand also insgesamt 17 okay das ist
dann also es ist schon wirklich hart 18
euro für 500 gramm tafel schokolade
ja also günstig ist es aber trotzdem bin
ich mal gespannt ob die schmeckt ich
hoffe sie kommen auch an weil das ist
das letzte produkt was noch fehlt und
die ist schon seit einer woche unterwegs
ist halt ein bisschen schade leute
bisschen
die schokolade ist noch nicht angekommen
ist immer noch unterwegs aber ich habe
eine sache vergessen bleibe ich hier
meinen das habe ich auch noch bestellt
und zwar diese geile werbung von dem was
rund berlin heißt das glaube ich aber
dass kam ich auf den erkennt laden das
ist auf jeden fall heute morgen in
meinem briefkasten gelandet einfach nur
in summe ja das kommt von also hier
etwas anders aus ich denke aber mal das
muss das sein also was anderes kann es
eigentlich nicht sein okay also ich hab
da so ein tanktop bestellt das aber
eigentlich auch express auf den fotos
dann würde ich sagen okay
auf den fotos sah es besser aus aber es
ist einfach mal 1 3214 wollte jetzt kann
ich endlich mal fällt gar nicht auf dass
das nicht echt ist oder das hat übrigens
20 euro kostet wenn dir das video 5000
nicht bricht das nächste video einfach
in dem ok die eins und zwei und drei
belegen die mit haltung den arm
ja sagt wenn ihr sagt alex macht
unbedingt noch sympathisch macht mir
echt spaß und ich glaube man hat auch
gesehen dass das video ein bisschen
aufwendiger weil ich habe heute den
ganzen tag eigentlich daran gearbeitet
hast mir super sogar gern dann daumen
nach oben da und abonniert auch sehr
gern den kanal da würde ich mich sehr
freuen
trotzdem hat spaß gemacht leute danke
fürs zuschauen und wir sind uns die tage
wieder haut rein checkt krimi ab das was
mir